in 2011
the omnibus ndaa national defense
authorization act which is a giant
omnibus bill that we yearly use to
refund
a lot of things the military being
primary among them
had two provisions slotted into it this
was signed by obama in the last day of
the year 2011. yes and the last day of
the year 2011 is significant not because
it was a legally significant date but it
contained these two
provisions 1021 and 1022.
the
provisions well let's start with the
signing
by so he happened to be in hawaii on
december 31st
and where his home was right it was very
very good reason for him to be in hawaii
however by signing in hawaii
late in the day
that new year's eve on new year's eve
that ensured that the rest of the world
would have moved on to new year's eve
celebrations that's what not was not
paying attention at least the rest of
the us right
and arguably
these two provisions end the us
constitution now i know how preposterous
that sounds and i agree that there are
interpretations by which that would not
be the case but the problem is what
these provisions do if i remember
correctly him signing this is part of
why you could not bring yourself to vote
for him a second time it is absolutely
sufficient reason right there and i will
tell you a little bit of the history so
these provisions allow indefinite
detention without charge or trial of any
person including american citizens
picked up anywhere on earth for
effectively engaging in
terrorism or supporting those who do
so my point since this moment
since the moment that this thing was
signed was
terrorism is a magic word when the
executive branch uses that term they are
declaring your rights null and void you
don't have a second amendment right if
the federal government has the right to
put a black bag over your head and haul
you off and not tell your family where
you've gone and not
there's no rid of habeas corpus they
don't have to charge you you don't get
the right to see the evidence against
you you don't have a right to privacy oh
you're right you're a citizen no you're
a terrorist right and this is the reason
that you and i had a disagreement in the
car is because with them using the term
terrorism there are now three tiers of
citizens there are fully compliant
citizens who can go to whatever
restaurant they want
there are uncompliant citizens who have
resisted let's say vaccines that they
are mandated to take and are now
forbidden to go certain places
and then there is a third category which
is terrorists and the problem is you
have now seen what the federal
government does with this definition so
i
as as you know and as i think i've even
made clear already here
um
this is
by far worse
uh than
not being able to go in a restaurant
because you're not vaccinated
but it feels to me like it is
unnecessarily confusing and will
actually make it make it hard to make
the point to put these into a single
category you have
i think there's two categorization
schemes here you have um
you know vaccinated versus unvaccinated
and then you also have
has been declared or has not been
declared a terrorist and maybe you know
maybe that's not quite the right naming
of the categorizations categorization
scheme over here and there is i think i
said that wrong but you know maybe you
have to flip that one over um there is a
lot of overlap between those two
categorization schemes or at least a lot
of potential overlap um between the of
course you're still a citizen and you're
vaccinated groups in the two
categorization schemes and they know
you're not vaccinated and oh yeah i
didn't even might declare you a
terrorist group i think i think there is
likely to be
some considerable overlap there
but they're not
as as it is with the two different
categorization schemes they really are
complete categories there's not
muddiness between them you aren't
members of of
two things within a single
categorization scheme you know you
either are or you are not vaccinated and
of course there is some muddiness there
you know some some
places are now not letting you in if
you're not boosted so you know what is
fully vaccinated count for um that
definition will move um
but uh
the you know could you be
uh declared a terrorist well everyone
could be so everyone's in that could you
be given their definitions of malness
and disinformation
but
have you been
is the category and are you at risk of
being is a squidgier category here and i
guess i would say
this
between the nea of 2011
and uh and the new thing from february
7th from the
terrorism branch the government or
whatever it is
um
we are in
trouble
we are wait we are we're in a lot of
trouble as as a country as a democracy
that
the fact that most people
the vast majority of people won't have
any awareness of either of these things
ndaa from end of 2011 yes from just over
10 years ago still most people don't
have any idea of it right
and
you could any random person on the
street could legitimately claim well i i
just honestly don't know about that
right and that is
that doesn't make it okay that doesn't
make it any less terrifying but they
could honestly declare and it could be
true and i think it is true for the vast
majority people they don't know whereas
that first tier that first
categorization of two tiers that i'm
describing the vaccinated versus the
unvaccinated
in most places in this country as far as
i know although i do i think that there
are places like florida and and texas
where there is where this is much less
true
at least in the the blue cities and the
coasts
you actually cannot be existing in
society and not know
that there are now two tiers
if you have ever been asked to show your
papers and know they don't use that
language but if you've been asked to
just show your back support
then you know and you have no excuse and
the fact that you are pretending not to
know or pretending that it's not a big
deal that paves the way for this this
ndaa followed by the february 7th
declaration or whatever it was called
and that is far worse but what i'm
saying is the thing that everybody does
know that there is no excuse you can't
ask someone on the streets of new york
city or l.a or seattle or a whole bunch
of other cities did you know that there
you know that if you don't have you know
vaccine
evidence of vaccine you can't get into
restaurants of course they know because
they've shown their papers every time
they have gone in of course they know
well and so they are complicit i think
they don't have any right not to know
it's in front of them i think they know
if they are showing their passports
which they are well there's a question
about what no means and look i'm not
obviously i'm as troubled about this as
anyone but the question is how is the
magic trick done yes right and this is
falling into these these two things and
there and they're distinct
strategies i believe
that's fine
um but
to the extent that people are hearing
about the ndaa 2012 for the first time
here so why do we call it the ndaa 2012
because it was the 2012 bill in which
these were inserted
oh so he signed it on the last day of
2011 but it's it's the 2012 bill okay um
here's the thing you should check out
the new york times from the following
day right the new york times has
complete pdf versions uh from january
1st 2012.
yes now many of us
you're gonna have a hard time finding it
but um i've been through it
with a fine tooth comb now if somebody
can find it in there great i'm all ears
but my claim is you can see the aclu
which used to be a civil rights
litigation organization it's now become
a woke monstrosity
but the aclu will
validate that at least the
interpretation i've given you is a
credible interpretation it's not just me
and the aclu saying that what you will
also be unlikely to know
is that chris hedges and noam chomsky
sued the obama administration
over this these two provisions
a federal court ruled that chris hedges
had standing to sue that he was in fact
in danger of being targeted because he
had interviewed members of al-qaeda
and the way these provisions are written
that could plausibly put him in danger
of being indefinitely detained so let me
just since you had me show this site
before the aclu says
the breadth of the this is and this is
again from 2012 back when the aclu was
doing the honorable work the aclu was
formed to do rather than becoming though
what did you call the wilkes monstrosity
it has become now the breadth of the
ndaa's worldwide detention authority
violates the constitution and
international law because it is not
limited to people captured in an actual
armed conflict as required by the laws
of war and then just next paragraph
although president obama issued a
signing statement saying he had quote
serious reservations about the ndaa's
detention provisions the statement only
applies to how his administration would
use them and would not affect how the
allah is interpreted by subsequent
administrations
yes and the provisions
parenthetical are inconsistent with
fundamental american values they are
inconsistent with absolutely fundamental
values that actually go way before the
u.s constitution right get rid of habeas
corpus for example right um
so
among other things what we know is that
a federal court ruled that this was a
plausible interpretation enough that
they were willing to hear it right the
law was suspended as a result of that
and then a three-judge federal panel
reversed that and
put it back into force
now here's the problem
an ordinary law
were it to be used against you there
would be a mechanism for dealing with it
right there would be a court and you
could argue
that this was unconstitutional in this
case what the f what the executive
branch has effectively done is it has
given
itself the ability to declare someone a
terrorist
have that person disappear not explain
where they've gone until
the end of hostilities so presumably
that's the moment at which on a planet
of nearly 8 billion people there are no
more terrorists it is an implausible
moment they have given themselves the
ability to detain somebody without
explaining where they went without
showing anybody evidence and so do you
say it's until hostilities cease the end
of hostilities in the hostilities the
end of hostilities which is obviously an
absurdity they've declared the entire
world of battlefield they've said
terrorism is the style of battle they
get to define who's a terrorist and uh
then
you can you will be returned at the end
of hostilities which couldn't possibly
ever happen because there will always be
terrorists i mean
there's no description of how the code
pandemic ends it's the same thing with
the war on drugs it's all of these
things we establish something
which we then use to grant ourselves
special powers and there is no uh
termination
condition right so again this is the
most special of laws because it does
there's no check on it even if you say
that's impossible that any court would
listen to such a law the question is
well if you disappear and your family
doesn't know where you've gone
right because they've decided that
you're a terrorist and they can detain
you someplace and never tell anyone what
happened you're just a missing person
how do you get to a court and say the
federal government has violated you know
my right to see the evidence against me
you don't there's no court yeah um
and so anyway again you can say that's
preposterous your interpretation is
bizarre but the point is first of all a
federal court said that uh chris hedges
had standing to sue that he was in
danger of this happening to him
so it's that credible yeah right and um
i will also point out that when the
obama administration responded
their
bizarre response to this suit was not we
don't have those rights that's not what
it says their response was we already
had those rights
so in any case it does point out also
how much the disintegration of once
honorable and absolutely necessary
organizations like the aclu has also
paved the way for what we're living
through now right there were there were
you know plenty of people who disagreed
with particular things that the aclu may
have done but they were consistent
they defended
they defended everyone who was having
their rights trampled and
now what they're doing is shutting you
down if you think men can't become women
right that's that that seems to be the
you know the the reigning issue of the
day for them well men can't become women
as mal information
i don't it's a fact
ah you see but
i don't think it's mal information this
case because my information requires out
of context so is saying anything without
context and inherently malinformation
because it needs to be their context all
i said was men can't become women what
context right but that's my that's what
i just said um so mal information
requires that it be out of context i
believe well first of all the um
opinion in this case of whether or not
there is or is not context coming as it
does from a misdis and malinformer
herself
is effectively null and void because i
mean look the reason that you haven't
yet been hauled off to be indefinitely
detained without the right to see the
evidence against you is simply the good
graces of the federal government which
you apparently still exist in
indeed um
anyway look yeah it's a kafka trap right
and it's right there on this uh
department of homeland security yeah
website yeah they're not hiding it it's
written in garbage ease but you can sort
your way through it and the answer is
look
this is actually the thing we were
warned about it just is right this is
the tyranny it's not ambiguous right
this is them declaring factual
information that might cause people to
be upset and not trust the federal
government as terrorism and then
declaring that they have rights when it
comes to terrorists that extend up to
everything right
sorry that's check and mate right they
just did it to us right you can't say
facts without them declaring you a
terrorist and if you're a terrorist they
can do anything they want to you have no
constitutional rights you know this
isn't tyranny how is that not tyranny
right
you could talk about the weather
no probably not no here's what you do if
you don't want to fall under their
definition of misdis and mal information
the mdm of it all if you want to avoid
that you take the thing that we used to
be told if you can't say anything nice
don't say anything at all and you just
do the last part of that you just don't
say anything about it could you please
shut up alrighty and we're next time
we're not going to ask nicely that's
what it is that's what that's what we
are being told right it's a shot across
the bow now
do i expect to be disappeared i do not
because that would cause a problem which
is that it would reveal what they're up
to but you know there's a reason that
they are moving the chess pieces around
the board this way and we of course will
be the last to know what that is and i
guess just just to return to what seems
like a disagreement but i don't think
really is
i think these are two sets of strategic
moves that are happening in parallel one
of them is not noticed by almost anyone
because almost no one is paying
attention to the ndaa and the
terrorism
declaration from february 7th of this
year um
but the fact that
everyone who lives in um most of the
highly populated areas of the united
states
um has encountered either being asked to
show their papers or um knowing that
because they have no papers they cannot
go places knows damn well what is
happening and if they are not looking
that squarely uh in the face and going
this
this harkens bad things
then they need to start doing that you
need to at least recognize that this is
exactly that serious and now
what's happening in canada is not about
uh people saying you should not be
allowed to take a vaccine it is about
vaccine mandates it is the mandates and
you know obviously all this conversation
about ndaa and such has been u.s
specific but
uh you know as uh jordan peterson's
recent conversation with the honorable
brian peckford who i mentioned on last
week's live stream but didn't say a
whole lot about he is peckford is
bringing he's one of these the
uh
former first minister from newfoundland
who is the one remaining
uh living
member of the of the framer of the
constitutional charter from 1981 or 82
in canada
is bringing a lawsuit against against
canada because
what is happening there
is fundamentally unconstitutional and i
see no similar thing happening here
but it it needs to and frankly what's
happening with pegfort in canada is uh
absolutely 100 supported and revealed to
be supported by many canadians by what
is happening in ottawa and also at kutz
and at the ambassador bridge okay and
for my part
i will say we have to return to william
binney's formulation here william binney
being an
nsa officer
who um became a whistleblower
and when interviewed
what he said
was holding his this is when um
would have been a decade ago okay
he said we are this close to a turnkey
totalitarian state right and the key
insight here is turnkey right a
totalitarian state that doesn't feel
like a totalitarian state until they
turn the key and the point is the fact
that that state is being erected around
you is on the department of homeland
security's website right
right down to their propagandistic
graphic novels and their absurd
invitation to pre-bunk stuff right this
is the turnkey totalitarian state
putting up the last little pieces of the
structure that allows them look you've
got a set of definitions that no one who
has not taken a vow of silence could
possibly escape right you're going to be
guilty of misdis or mal information
whatever you do and that means that any
day they can decide your constitutional
rights are no longer rights at all which
means that your constitutional rights
are a privilege they've rendered these
things a privilege and that's what a
totalitarian state would do
so um
have they turned the key will they turn
the key we don't know but we need to
understand that the danger of the
turnkey totalitarian state is not the
turning of the key the danger is the
erection of the thing which they've done
[Music]